since the beginning McLaren has been
known for one thing fast cars
the 52 year old British brand is one of
the oldest racing teams ever and one of
the most successful in 2009 the company
took their racing expertise and started
selling consumer supercars and the
company made a commitment to bring out a
new car every year this year McLaren
Automotive is unveiling something
totally different a car that will
challenge the likes of the Porsche 911
Oddie r8 and Ferrari California it's a
car with a mere 180 thousand dollar
price tag a fire sale for a McLaren it's
called the 570s
the idea of the affordable supercar has
been years in the making
do you forgive us if we're a little bit
nervous because you are the very first
journalists in the world that we've
shown the McLaren Sport Series to the
570s was conceived at McLaren super
secret and posh development centre in
Woking England
visitors must pass through multiple
security gates and long corridors locked
on each end
the elevators are activated only by
security key
it might seem extreme until you remember
that this is where they are making some
of the fastest machines on earth
including the new McLaren Formula one
cars and the new 570s
tell me a little bit for how this car
will be used as opposed to previous
MacLaren's that we've seen it's our most
accessible car to date although it's
supercar design the sports car segment
with its 526 horsepower and 180 thousand
dollar price tag mclaren executives say
the 570s is their ticket to tripling
sales volumes worldwide the whole form
of the car was to show the way the air
flows around the car from the very first
moment the air touches the nose of the
bumper the car is a mid-engine
rear-wheel drive v8 coupe that thanks to
a carbon fiber chassis weighs just over
2800 pounds it's supposed to be
something that you could drive every day
if you want to
so it's more luxurious inside than any
of its predecessors feels open most
spacious center console designs changed
a lot and we've also taken every
opportunity to increase the amount of
stowage so more practical is that an
oxymoron practical supercar possibly if
you can achieve it then you want
something special
production numbers for the 570s haven't
been set yet but expect to see it by the
end of the year which is great because
unlike pretty much every other luxury
car brand McLaren says it will never
build an SUV they're doing something new
it's a gamble and they're placing all
bets on the 570s
[Music]